well I missed the big stock market crash
early in the week my daughter had a my
oldest daughter had her third child our
fifth grandchild right after the Super
Bowl is over so welcoming to the world
Samuel David and we love grandbabies
around our place if we didn't know how
great grandbabies were going to be we'd
have been nicer to their parents I love
them so Papa dave is celebrating we love
having them around and exciting so I
took the day off yesterday to hang out
with the baby and the mommy and the
daddy and all that stuff and the other
babies taking care of them and all that
sighs yeah that's fun times good times
oh and in the middle of that apparently
we've all lost all of our fortunes
you're gonna retire broke now did you
know that apparently I mean wild trading
session front page of every single news
I let how like I told you a couple
months ago we're in there just a few
weeks ago actually I said you know stock
market setting all kinds of records up
and nobody says anything about it but as
soon as it takes a dive everybody's got
it on the front page you remember me you
remember me telling you that of course
it stabilized again today so we don't
know what we're doing there if you
didn't know January was the biggest
uptick in one month in the stock market
since March of 16 so basically in the
last two years January was the biggest
up month and whatever it made in January
lost all of it in one day right and so
well you were up 20% last year in your
mutual funds if you were in decent
mutual funds and I mean anything
anywhere near the sp500 would put you up
20% in the year 17
so in January it went up a record month
and here in the first week of February
it drops all of what it gained in
January and it's on the front page of
everything and you
lost everything now you're just you're
gonna retire broke and there's gonna be
bread lines and he says sarcastically
and rolls his eyes again reminding you
that no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off mid
ride don't do that enjoy the ride all
the way around and what you've got to do
is continually invest throughout your
lifetime just be continuous investor I
have never once I started investing in
the stock market I've never stopped
I have not pulled all my money out and I
have not tried to get all my money in
when it was down now I've been tempted a
couple of times two times I remember I
was tempted to find some money scratched
together the nickels out of the corner
of the couch and try to get some extra
money into the market because I thought
it was unusually down and that would
have been of course the last one was the
2008 crash when it bottomed out at 6,500
I thought it had bottomed out before it
did I would have bought a little bit
above that wrote it on down and come on
back out but think if you have bought at
6,400 and it's at 24,000 now is that
like tripling your money yeah it is
$25,000 right $24,000
is 24 for those of you help you with
that
so $6,000 it becomes a $24,000 three
times your money that's how that works I
wish I had bought their extra I bought
their but I didn't buy extra there I
mean so if I put in a million dollars I
have three million dollars in that one
account right now you know that would
have been nice the other one and I was
right on this one too and I just didn't
do it because I just resist this idea
that I'm trying to look for the bottom
of the market I don't I just steadily
invest I'm ridiculously nerdy about
steady investing was y2k any of you
remember y2k 18 years ago you remember
the world was going to come to an end
because the computers weren't going to
flip and the grid was gonna crash the
electrical grid was going to crash food
shortages and you need bullets and guns
and water and you need remember all
with y2k if you were if you're you know
I guess if you're 30 years old you were
12 when that happened right so you have
some vague memory of your parents doing
it so you got to be 40 years old - I've
been a working adult really when y2k
happened so that one's kind of getting
old but I remember y2k I mean it doesn't
world the market went down from Jun
approximately a steady decrease it
wasn't a dive but a steady decrease from
June through December and I should have
bought in June because it was
anticipating this great financial
turmoil due to y2k do the computer
problems and the weird thing was I
thought the market that where I was
wrong I thought the market would drop in
January
like first week of January it would dive
and you could buy then and that's what I
was gonna do I was gonna time it out and
buy when it dove right after y2k the
weird thing was the market had
anticipated all of the problems or
Corrections or whatever and a lot of
people of course had fixed their
computers and so y2k was a was a
colossal yawn and the market never dove
in January as soon as the bell rang you
know twelve thirty one is over one one
is here you know the stock market opens
back up that January if you go back and
look January of the year 2000
what it do shot straight up because it
had already corrected for all of the
costs associated with converting the
computers for y2k that caused company
profits to go down but it had also
corrected for the emotions and it would
have nothing but celebrate it shot
straight up after that that's the two
times I've been tempted to buy at the
bottom both times would have been
correct except I would have missed
because I would have waited until
January I went to Kay but if I had
bought in June of 99 that were really up
to about October of 99 that would have
been your good low point to get in and
you would have made some serious money I
have to go back let's see what the Dow
was then
probably three thousand something can
you imagine yeah I mean we used to think
if the Dow ever broke ten thousand that
it would be the world would crack open
and then we thought if it broke twenty
thousand in the world would crack open
and guys we drove past twenty thousand
so fast none of you saw it and then it
corrects for one week and everybody goes
bananas so all of that to say you're
gonna be okay keep investing the people
that make money in their mutual funds
are not the ones that time the market
there's all kinds of data points and all
kinds of studies all kinds of research
this is don't time the market don't try
to buy it when it's low sell it when
it's high don't try to figure out when
it's peaked just keep buying
incrementally every month just keep
buying that's all the data points tell
us on that what's what the millionaire's
do if you want to be one that's what you
do nobody gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off mid ride this
is the Dave Ramsey show